et pour en parler de ces manifestations
nous sommes ce soir avec fatima benomar
fondatrice de l'association les
effrontés et lui devine de l'archère
président de la manif pour tous
bienvenu merci à toutes les deux d'être
sur ce plateau pour débattre de cette
question lui devine de la recherche me
tourne d'abord vers vous il y a eu 60
une soixantaine de villes avec ces
manifestations
pourquoi aujourd'hui on l'a entendu il
ya un contexte de crise sanitaire
pourquoi prendre ces risques
alors qu' il vaut mieux rester chez soi
alors on a vu que malgré la crise
sanitaire et dans la plus grande
discrétion
emmanuel macron sans le dire dans aucune
de ces allocations publiques a voulu
faire avancer en catimini pendant l'été
ce projet de loi de bioéthique dit de
bioéthique
donc elle a passé la seconde lecture à
l'assemblée nationale dans des
conditions invraissemblables avec un
débat utile et sans vote solennel des
ministres qui ont été largement absents
et pendant ce temps là le gouvernement
ne cessez de dieu la priorité des
priorités c'est l'emploi et le fait
qu'il avance avec ce projet de loi est
l'étape suivante la seconde lecture au
sénat le calendrier l'étape suivante
n'est pas encore fixée mais nous
voulions et nous devons impérativement
être présent dans la rue pour exprimer
le fait que ce projet de loi propose de
grands problèmes alors c'était 60
manifestations pour respecter bien sûr
la protection de la santé de tous ceux
qui voulaient défiler qui voulait
s'exprimer dans la rue
nous avons évité un grand rassemblement
national trop nombreux en démultipliant
les lieux de rendez-vous 60
manifestations
c'est exceptionnel aucun parti aucun
groupement ou syndicats ne fait de
telles démonstrations de force
alors il y avait aussi des
contre-manifestations aujourd'hui fatima
benomar vous en étiez j'imagine pourquoi
c'est contre-manifestation vous dites
pour couvrir les voix
ça sert à quoi non je n'ai pas fait
partie des manifestations pour ma part
parce que ça fait quand même huit ans
qu'on manifeste et qu'on débat sur cette
question sur la foi d'une promesse
d'ailleurs qui a été fait dès 2012 par
l'ancien candidat françois hollande
d'ouvrir la pma à toutes les femmes aux
couples de femmes aux femmes
célibataires et là ce qu'on veut c'est
très très vite le vote définitif
la promulgation et le fait de sécuriser
les familles et d'ailleurs je voyais les
manifestations parler au nom des
français pour le coup les sondages sont
toujours restés favorables au droit des
femmes de fonder des familles et des
familles homoparentales et c'est fou les
mensonges aussi qu'on continue à
entendre dans ces manifestations par
rapport à la filiation en moins à
l'enfant déjà en général quand on a
recours à une pma on n'a pas besoin de
mentir un enfant est en général
d'ailleurs dans les couples de même sexe
vous imaginez bien que l'enfant est bien
assez tôt au courant qu'il a était issue
d'une pma contrairement au couple deux
hétéros en fait qui ont recours à une
pma qui peuvent parfois se permettre de
mentir à leurs enfants aient eu en fait
nos opposants ce n'est pas
l'établissement de la filiation par un
parent qui n'est pas biologique qui les
gênent même à l'extrême droite marion
maréchal-le pen d'ailleurs qui a rajouté
maréchal dans son nom de famille est
complètement pour la reconnaissance et
la parfaitement reconnu que son père non
biologique s'est occupé d'elle l'a
reconnu et donc que c 'est c'est son
père donc la pérennité en france elle
est déclaratif quant à l'homme est en
couple avec une femme si elle accouche
il est reconnu par la loi et pas besoin
de faire un test et donc c'est le projet
familial qui prime dans le sel
exactement à la même chose je vous le
donne en mille
pour les couples de femmes et ben quand
elle fonde une famille quand elles
s'occupent de leurs enfants et ben elle
devrait être reconnu et signer miremont
songe qui fait à leurs enfants c'est
tout simplement l'établissement d'un
projet familial et d'ailleurs on voit
que ces sujets ne ment pas nos opposants
s'il s'agit de couples de sexe opposé
alors on va pas refaire tout le débat on
a beau
beaucoup parler évidemment de tout c'est
tous ces détails du texte de loi
c'est le moment en fait qui est
important aujourd'hui on est en pleine
crise sanitaire 56% des français c'est
un autre sondage publié hier pense que
le projet de loi aurait pu être
reportées vu le contexte il ya d'autres
priorités vous ne pensez pas un fatima
binôme a toujours eu d'autres priorités
de 2012 c'est à dire que quand est ce
qu'on va reconnaître le droit de ces
personnes de fonder une famille en
abstraction à tout ce qui peut se passer
ailleurs dans le monde il va toujours y
avoir malheureusement des crises
économiques des crises politiques des
débuts terrorisme et cetera en fait il
va on va ces familles ne peuvent pas
attendre qu'on ait résolu tous les
problèmes de l'univers et tous ceux qui
vont se poser et la crise écologique et
que sèche pour qu'on s'occupe d'elle et
d'ailleurs ça a toujours été comme ça
par rapport à tous les droits
reproductifs notamment droits des femmes
si je vous savez ce jour raconte t il on
va faire la révolution on rêve on va
résoudre le problème puis après on
s'occupera des bonnes femmes c'est pas
possible
à un moment il faut inscrire nos droits
dans l'agenda ne serait ce que par
rapport après la promesse de la pma sa
fille de huit ans qu'on attend et il y
aura toujours des conjonctures et il
faudra repousser jusqu'à quand elle les
devine de la recherche c'est un argument
que vous mettez en avant le coût
justement de la prise en charge puisque
c'est pma devraient être remboursés par
la sécurité sociale
on le sait qui est qui est mise à mal
aujourd'hui à cause du coc vide
donc c'est pour moi un argument
supplémentaire alors le sujet essentiel
de ce projet de loi les sujets il ya
beaucoup de sujets dans ce projet de loi
il y à la pma dans un contexte qui
volontairement pris 20 enfants de pères
toute sa vie ça c'est fondamental
un père dans la vie de tout enfant c'est
très important et une mère mais mme
demers inscrits sur son acte de
naissance et c'est là que nous parlions
d'un mensonge un enfant n'a pas de maire
il pu avoir une mairie une belle-mère
mais une mer où deux femmes ne remplace
pas un père c'est une injustice immense
s'étend sur la vraie vie il ya des
enfants qui n'ont pas de pair meetic
alors il ya les sacs les aléas de la vie
qui malheureusement fou que des enfants
sont privés de leur père pour toutes
sortes de raisons
là la différence qu'on veut
volontairement privé des enfants de
pères et on veut les fassiez il
disparaît même de son acte de naissance
on prétendrait qu'il a deux mamans ce
qui n'est pas vrai encore une fois il
peut avoir une berline belle-mère oui
bien sûr c'est pas le c'est pas la
question
l'autre chose c'est que dans ce projet
de loi de bioéthique il faut savoir
qu'il y a aussi la volonté de créer des
embryons génétiquement modifiés des
embryons humains 2 me de créer aussi des
embryons chimères animal hommes il y a
la volonté de créer des gammes est
artificielle et de les féconder etc etc
et donc ce projet de loi pose des
questions humaines et éthiques
immense et pour en revenir à la pma qui
intéresse plus particulièrement madame
et madame je vous invite à regarder le
reste du projet de loi et ses
conséquences et un penser à l'avenir il
y a néanmoins un fait qui est que
l'enfant n'est pas un droit
un enfant vous parler de projet familial
projet parental
il n'y a pas de droit à fonder une
famille ça n'existe pas il n'y a pas de
droit à l'enfant
vous réclamez des droits des droits des
droits mais qu'est ce que vous faites de
ces enfants que l'eau volontairement au
prix dre de père est donc ce n'est pas
acceptable et d'ailleurs vous parliez
des sondages donc tous les sondages qui
se succèdent
quand on parle de l'enfant qui le
premier concerné par la pma avant les
adultes et bien 85% des français
répondent que évidemment l'enfant né par
pma a le droit d'avoir un père et une
mère comme tous les enfants et pour
revenir au calendrier actuel ce sont des
sujets fondamentaux des sujets avec des
conséquences anthropologique humaine
éthique immense le fait est que excusez
moi
le gouvernement a devant lui des
urgences absolues
ils n'arrêtent pas de dire la priorité
des priorités c'est l'emploi c'est la
crise et en fait est ce qu il a fait cet
été il a passé en catimini et en douce
sur ce projet de loi pour le faire
avancer
et le gouvernement n'est pas à l'aise il
sait très bien que ça n'est pas vrai
quand on pose les questions précises sur
ce qu'implique ce projet loin les
réponses sont tout à fait différentes
et de fait encore une fois aujourd'hui
malgré un contexte qui est inquiétant
pour tout le monde
malgré la difficulté d'organiser des
rassemblements
il y avait beaucoup de français partout
dans la rue aujourd'hui
et ce sont des français qui sont pas là
à dire mes droits mais droit mais droit
et le monde à faire mes intérêts
personnels
ils sont dans la rue pour défendre le
plus faible enfants pour défendre aussi
le respect de l'intégrité de l'être
humain
l'écologie on ne cesse d'en parler on a
dévasté la faune la flore la terre
l'environnement et on est en train avec
des apprentis sorciers qui veulent faire
des embryons transgéniques et des
embryons chimérique
on envisage aussi de dévaster de ne pas
respecter tout simplement la nature
humaine
ce projet de loi est éminemment grave et
dans un tel contexte aussi grave qu
aujourd'hui c'est bien particulier ça
n'est pas le moment il faut prendre du
recul
il faut prendre du temps il faut être
serein et peut-être aussi prendre en
compte
justement les questions écologiques et
cette crise sanitaire qui a montré toute
la vulnérabilité de l'homme qui a montré
aussi la difficulté pour la médecine
d'exercer sa tâche immense et complexe
et la médecine
elle n'est pas là pour mener d utiliser
des techniques médicales pour des femmes
qui sont ces comptes je le rappelle est
elle n'est pas là non plus pour réaliser
nos désirs individuels
ce sont toutes ces questions que madame
vous refusé d'évoquer vous ne voulez pas
réfléchir aux conséquences
et ça fait des années que je débats et
je vois que jamais les coincer par les
fatima benomar qui veut répondre et
débattus vous vouliez répondre fatima
benomar oui absolument c'est évidemment
diffamatoire ça fait des années qu'on
travaille dans le détail pour fabre
enrichir cette loi qu'on est auditionné
à l'assemblée nationale pour répondre
dans les détails c'est extrêmement mai
crise en est violent de dire que les
couples de mer ne s'occupe pas au droit
du droit des enfants et de leur
bien-être dans toutes les les cas
d'adoption et de filiation on n'a jamais
vu qu'ils avaient un dédain de la part
de ses parents par rapport à leurs
enfants on ne voit pas et que les
enfants qui sont adoptés par des parents
de même sexe soient plus malheureux et
c'est là aussi c'est complètement encore
une fois de la stigmatisation des
projets parentaux bien sûr qu'elles
s'occupent des droits de leurs enfants
maintenant ce qui est important c'est de
renforcer ses droits c'est à dire de ne
pas faire de la pma effectivement adroit
de riches il faut est tout simplement le
remboursement afin de permettre ces
projets et ce par ailleurs et je suis
absolument par ailleurs d'accord avec
vous sur la question de d'arrêter de
maltraiter la nature et bien typiquement
nous souhaiterions que dans cette loi en
prennent en compte d'ailleurs la
question des intersexe parce que ça ne
semble pas beaucoup vous déranger mais
aujourd'hui à des opérations qui ont
sont faites sur des bébés et des
traitements médicaux qui leur sont
imposées quand il ya des enfants
intersexe à l'encontre de toutes les
recommandations internationales qui est
des nombreuses interpellations de l'onu
mais là quand il s'agit de se conformer
au fond au fantasme pour faire bricoler
des enfants à l'image de ce que l'on
soit là il ya aucun problème
on peut donner le coup de pistolet en
des bébés pour faire des personnes et
des filles
contrairement à ce que la nature avait
prévu elle donc les noms sommes
absolument pas dans les guides 1 du
destin de ces enfants nous souhaitons
c'est que les haies lors leur parcours
et on n'a jamais vu qui est
statistiquement plus d'enfants qui une
fois grandi disent qu'ils sont
particulièrement leurs beaux endroits
ont été particulièrement bafouée et par
rapport à cette histoire de beau-père ou
de belle-mère là aussi c'est une
différenciation que vous faites
selon les familles par exemple quand un
père adoptif reconnaît un enfant vous
demandez pas ce qu'ils soient reconnus
comme un beau père monsieur maréchal
pour prendre cet exemple un peu cocasse
parce qu'il s'agit de quelqu'un qui
manifestent avec la manif pour tous
n'est pas reconnu comme le beau père de
marion le pen elle
son nom de famille et c'est devenu son
père parce qu'il a reconnus par ce qui
s'est occupé d'elle et parce qu'ils lui
l'établissement de cette filiation
il nous est très très peu de temps un
mot du domaine de la recherche comparer
ce qui n'est pas comparable vous savez
très bien que dans le cas d'un homme et
une femme c'est une filiation
vraisemblable et vous parlez des enfants
orphelins orphelins parce que la vie les
a rendus orphelins ils sont adoptés par
des familles aimantes oui parce qu'on
essaie de réparer au mieux leur
situation et malgré cela vous savez très
bien que la plupart d'entre eux
cherchent à connaître leurs parents qui
sont des parents charnel aussi il les
cherche un temps de parole égal jacques
30 secondes par les cherche mais vous
êtes dans le déni des besoins de tout
être humain
l'amour c'est aussi de savoir renoncer à
ses propres désirs
par respect pour autrui et je ne je ne
dis pas du tout comme les ivor la
filiation et saucier sur un projet
parental pourquoi vous demandez la gérer
il ya une réalité il n'y a pas d'enfant
sans a nommé une femme et vous êtes dans
le déni de rêve de la réalité besoin de
connaître l'homme et la femme dont ils
sont nés cesse de passion merci beaucoup
c'est là c'est la fin de ce débat il
nous reste peu de temps malheureusement
ça mériterait davantage qu'on s'y penche
merci à toutes les deux en tout cas
d'être en direct et avoir débattu en
direct ce soir sur arte france